okay
hello and welcome to our expert webinar
uh the ai trends and fintech that are
changing digital economy job roles
um today we're speaking with rishi mera
uh ceo of ishfin
uh before we introduce rishi i'd like to
cover a couple of things about how to
use the controls
um please put your questions for rishi
into the q a box
and rishi if you'd mute yourself for a
moment i think we're getting feedback
right um
please put your questions for rishi in
the q a box
we will log those and when we reach the
q
a part of our presentation at the end
he'll be able to address those
um if you have comments for
him please put them in the chat
but address them to all panelists
otherwise you won't see them
and we're going to be doing several
polls
um i'm going to start with this one
which is one we ask
at the beginning of each of our webinars
and
the two questions are how much
experience do you have
i'd like to get a feel for the audience
of whether we're
speaking with um working professionals
or people just entering the workforce
and we also like to check your
kind of well-being we know that this is
a
critical time especially for our
audience in india so we want to know
whether you're
doing well and
staying safe
so we have four three two one and
the poll is
complete and i will share the results
with you
we have a experienced audience today
almost half are five years and more of
experience
and fortunately the vast majority of you
are doing well for those who are not we
hope that
things will get better and we hope that
the webinar actually will give you
information that you can use and
so let's go ahead and
introduce rishi
uh florisha mehra you see on your screen
is the ceo of wishfin he has
over 15 years of experience um has
started
more than one company and has
emphasis on product innovation and
customer service
um in i.t and in finance and
his master's is from durham
university in the uk so welcome rishi
it's great to have you today
thanks to it um before we
start i'd like to get uh an orientation
for you
about the audience um and the
familiarity with fintech
so that you have a feel for you know
what what you need to address
so i'm going to start the second poll
here
and you know if you work in fintech
great
uh if you're very familiar with it um
great if you're not familiar with it
that's important information for rishi
to know so that he can familiarize
you
and if there's any disaster with my web
camera today
it will be because i have a cat
who may jostle it so
please don't be surprised and we'll
finish the poll
in 10 seconds
and here are the answers so half of our
audience is
unfamiliar with
fintech um but we do have some people
who are working in the field
and others who are familiar with it so
that gives you rishi an idea of right
you know who we're talking to and
what i'd like to do is um allow you to
introduce
yourself in terms of what does wishfin
do and and how do you do it
right hi guys uh uh thank you stuart for
putting this all together and the idea
to uh make people understand and learn
and how to grow themselves as as uh
as as an as a part of name for
you know tech circle and functions like
that i'll be glad to share
my uh you know my experiences across
so i'm part of vishwan uh we founded
this in 2016.
uh wish finn helps consumer make
responsible financial decisions the idea
is customer has wishes
and there is an end to me to wishes so
end to meet wishes
can be both by taking credit or by
helping customers understand
their financial balance sheet and make
them safe so that they can make this
financial decision
which is right for them either taking it
by credit or by saving small amount of
money
so they can own the product and
themselves so
when you're creating this idea what we
understood was that
a lot of times when you're trying to
reach your long-term
goals uh it is very difficult to
maintain a life cycle
or discipline of 15 20 years that's why
you know when you look at a lot of
people who try
retirement plans et cetera on that
period of time uh
at some period of time they do not see
the value of it they see
evaluate it too often and then they they
realize that they will not make it or
they some of them
just do not uh bring the enough money
that is required for their retirement
plans etc
so that's where we wish when we realized
that we have to eventually analyze
people have to segment them and
understand them
use a lot of tech and understand them by
understanding their credit history by
giving them the credit report free
which will make us enhance our data sets
when we are able to enhance our data
sets
we will be able to work much more uh you
know better for them to understand where
they are
and able to guide them so that's what we
wish for now we currently help a lot
of computer consumers there's about
seven million of consumers have taken
credit report from us there has been
uh you know we help disperse about uh
you know 100 million
uh loans uh in a year so that's where we
are about
yeah wonderful so um given
that about half the audience isn't
familiar with
fintech can you give us a kind of a
timeline or
or how the fintech sector
emerged and why it's different from
traditional banking
yeah so you know the first examples of
fintech we talk about
you know when they actually came to
existence where finance and technology
both
together was the invention of an atm
where we said
there is a there is a machine that was
built
which could talk to consumers on its own
and derive results
as desired by the customer so it started
in 60s where
the you know atms were built and then
a lot of people realized that you know
uh you know this whole industry is a
very different industry all together
across
because then things changed was that the
laptop and the pcs came across
people happened to visit banks and
branches in the 70s and 80s
to do transactions they were costly for
consumers
and for the banks to service them so now
when you have a lot of
cost for an example if you visit a bank
or a branch
there's a cost to a bank and bank is
obviously going to charge you for the
cost in somewhere some other way
right either by taking the upfront fee
for that
or having a fee which is uh which is a
service fee etc etc on that front
so when the when the computers came
forward so
you know the same thing that you did
actually you know by visiting a branch
uh came much cheaper to the bank so the
bank became
start passing on a much more better buck
to you when you're trying to do that and
that's how the
fintech revolution started in the 80s
and 90s and this was understood
that if you're able to you know take the
middleman away take the middle layers
away
you will be able to give much more to
the consumer and the consumer will
eventually take it to a next life cycle
where we either save more
take credit more and understand or be
able to fulfill whatever is required
across on that front so so in the 90s to
2000
you know the mobile phones started
coming in with the mobile phones
the the piece changed drastically
because you know
you need to know what the balance that
you need to have you need to know
how much i can invest for a single day
how can how can i put a
a fixed deposit in a some day how where
i can invest i had
the googles of the world which were
telling me what was the comparison all
about
you know you earlier you know if you had
to go to a branch the physical branch
that you had to go
you would felt you know it's like window
shopping and going to a bank and
understand how much is available across
on that front
in my 80s and 90s internet revolution
changed that
and from then onwards all the models
which are becoming successful
are on the layer of giving comparisons
giving value-add to a customer where he
becomes the king
and reducing the cost for customers and
reducing the cost of brokerage reducing
the cost of
making one single transaction and that's
how the fintech
came into the power right and it's
creating a level playing fields for
consumers creating
a much better consumer experience and
ensuring
a lot of people are able to save or
decide better what they were used to
about 10 20 30 years and it is
changing to such a drastic level that
you know
we feel that in in five to ten years
a physical branch would never exist
anymore it will be a zombie field you
know across on that period of time
yeah so that's the part of it yeah and
and
i am old enough to remember
the savings pass book which went out of
um
out of style in the united states many
years ago but
when i was a child and got a savings
account
there the little pass um
report um in paper form
that the bank teller would stamp and
write in the amount of any uh
transaction and
now of course it's an entirely different
world
so what has changed in fintech
over the last year now that we've we've
been
forced into isolation to work at home
and non-contact models what are what are
some of the the big things that have
changed over the last year
yeah so so uh you know over the years
uh you know uh when we were talking
about fintech and people be able to make
decisions on the internet or on a mobile
phone
uh what first thing that was required
was that
when you have gone into a pandemic where
touch
uh you know or are getting closer to a
people that you don't do
how do fintech could solve that and with
the help of artificial intelligence
you know onboarding a customer right
that was one big uh you know problem
area because you had to had initial
stages have to take up a physical
photograph
have to make somebody sign something
like that and then the bank wanted to
understand whether the person was signed
is the same person or not so the the
impact of that of
onboarding you know was typically
happening from a long period of time
but during the covert uh you know people
also understood that
while they're trying to buy something
from a bank
or they're trying to do a transaction uh
it has to be
you know there has to be no contact and
so the first thing came forward was that
you know the fraud detection of is the
person who wants
a product is himself has taken a drastic
leap in a country like in india also and
abroad also across on that
so during uh you know the corvette the
first problem was solved then the
problem was
if you're trying to operate an account
open an account can you open it
just by you know doing three clicks yes
that made possible that was existent
earlier also
but uh fintech ensured that these models
became
robust they ensured that even if there
is one single last signature required
was taken away and why was it taken away
that it was able to understand with deep
learning
that whether you the photograph that
you're giving
right or you're taking a selfie and
you're attaching a document
can a deep learning understand it's the
same person
right can from your mobile phone
understand the
geographical location of yours and
tagging you to into that profile to
understand
whether you stay rather than doing a
physical verification
so these are the major trends that have
happened across and what has
happened is entitled to a lot of
consumers to make
transactions easy from their end from
their homes or from their mobile phones
that last point by the way is a
fascinating aspect of fintech and i had
heard about it
only recently in in the notion that
facial recognition which is very
controversial in a lot of countries
is a really useful tool
in your sector because it allows
people it allows you to verify identity
um in a way that's much as you said much
simpler than trying to
use other types of verification
techniques
um and yet
as i mentioned it's your controversial
number of countries because people
associate it with
surveillance and privacy invasion and
that type of thing
yeah but um you know it illustrates how
different technologies
or the same technology in different
applications uh can have wildly
different um correct correct so i have
my
yeah yeah so i have my viewpoints is
that once you're
on boarding and you're allowing these
apps to take privacy
you should onboard it only while
allowing these apps when you're taking
up a decision not giving them a free
access all the time
that helps consumer maintain its privacy
and ensure
you know uh the juice that you want to
take out of from an onboarding function
helps you out on that but you know
otherwise what happens is that if you're
trying to take up a product
your and in pandemic or non-pandemic can
go into a branch
if you can do it but it becomes much
easier
uh so and there are times when when a
lot of these fintechs will never have a
physical address
they will never have a branch right and
if they are offering
a half a percent higher interest rate
for you
you know you might it will be lucrative
because they don't have a branch
just saving that cost right so to save
that cost if that is required and if you
can maintain your privacy
if your fintech player allows you to
maintain your privacy in the control
that if you have it at the time of the
use uh i think it becomes a win-win for
everyone
yeah that's an excellent point in the
difference between
a permission-based privacy exchange and
a permissionless um use of
of personal information um
so what we're looking at coming ahead
and i think that
the name of the webinar uh is looking at
the trends coming
you know both in this year and in future
years what do you see coming ahead in in
fintech how is that going to change
both you know the way you do business
and the people you need to help you to
do that
yeah so uh so uh technically we see
all the big banks and the fintech
players they're going to become
uh you know either they're going to you
know you know
get deep involved with each other build
products for themselves
or have these apis where they get
you know integrated with each other and
try to bring
a customer experience and move out of
the branch
the atms in everything that is required
at that period of time
so you know so as we've spoken earlier
yes that was one part of it
the second part is that we would move
down to a structure
where where a lot of uh you know open
structures will be available to
customers where they'll be able to
understand
how their money is being kept where it
is where it has been invested
having a clear understanding uh and
reducing
fees from the consumers will become uh
you know
very prominent as there is something
called direct plans
in mutual funds in india which has
become very popular
right and then there are even on there
there is something like early edfs and
then this is all about doing
you're doing it yourself and save money
kind of prepositions
which would have also changed a lot of
stuff in even
when you do stock trading like the robin
hoods of the world
and india zero those of the world have
changed uh insured
lot lot more youngsters come into and do
trading which
i mean uh i i may have my different
views on that but giving an access
is what fintech's been able to do that
make them understand
make them be part of the society which
was considered
as to be uh you know championed by a few
people who who were not data driven
right and who were
just giving advice on the five or seven
rules across on that front
so that's what i see a large term change
across on that front yeah
the next part that i see is that you
know as there was somebody mentioning in
other blockchains would you know be a
part of these whole ecosystems and
change a lot of stuff
uh you know the way we do banking and
you know uh
and it's it's a matter of time about
about two to three years where
blockchain will become the basic uh
structure where the banking would start
working across on that front and
whatever
infra that you see at this period of
time would change across
very quickly and way uh yeah
sorry i can't hear you i think you've
gone on mute yeah
yes i apologize
and we think of blockchain as
cryptocurrency now but it's
it's we're also it's beginning to
penetrate
the popular consciousness with things
like nfts
and people are beginning to say okay
well it's not just
bitcoin it must have some other
use and so um i think as
more people understand
what it can do the acceptance of
different applications of it is going to
increase
that's just one example of a particular
technology there's so many
um when you look at these
these trends how
do fintech firms position themselves
and what kind of plans are they making
to take advantage of these trends where
do you
where do you kind of see them um
you know trying to bring new services to
consumers and
and borrowers and yeah so
uh you know so with the software in the
invent of software and artificial
intelligence the fintechs
are are are you know the difference
between fintechs
uh and the large banks was that fintechs
were driven by technology
right and the banks were serving
customers
that's what i see that to cross banks
started quickly you know they started
serving customers fintech said
let's talk technology first and develop
a product and they would go to a
consumer
the first things largely that you think
fintechs have been able to do and there
was a
fellow person asking a question across
on that one but how do deep learning
uh you know solve a lot of frauds across
from that front
right uh what we figured out was that
the first thing that we solved was that
fraud detection understand the same
person who's trying to onboard is the
same person
with deep learning understanding of you
being
able to you know take your photographs
and
crack it into a million bits of pieces
and you even if you have a beard around
it and being able to understand that's
the same person
this was not possible at a period of
time which was
before it could you do it with deep
learning now when you are able to match
and you able to imagine that in you know
two five seconds
uh you know i i'll give you an example
if you go to facebook they're able to
recognize in any photograph that has
been posted by someone that you're
tagged in
right imagine in billions and billions
of those photographs
where the tech being able to understand
this is your photograph and you've been
tagged to and the fintechs
will have that kind of uh technology
pieces will be understand that this is
the you person
and they'll be able to understand all
your product
is being used or you're being used
across on that front uh
so that's where it's it's it's going to
detect
the and and ensure that the fraudulent
practices become much reduced
because machine learning and algorithms
are able to understand
and identify what people are trying to
fool the systems
so that's the first part second part is
that they will be able to solve
and segment consumers as per what they
need uh you know typically when fintechs
came in space
uh you know we realized that there are a
lot of consumers
who's at a period of time are taking the
first product
they don't have a credit history right
uh they are underserved because
everybody wants to serve the banks said
they want to serve a person which has a
high fico score in uis or a high credit
bureau scoring
india across on that front but how much
percentage
of that people across on that front so
fintechs were able to understand that
even if you serve to a guy who's
under at uh you know who's not a perfect
scorer but he can make money for you
and you can revive his care life cycle
right
is the perfect win which can only happen
if you use technology and artificial
intelligence by branching out that
customer
right if you're not able to branch out
and segment that customer very well
nobody will be able to win either you
will charge him higher rate of interest
which he'll never be able to pay or you
will be able
to put him in the right segment which
the interest is fine for him
and he can get that credit and move his
life cycle more and pay that credit
and the financial institution and the
individuals both have a win
there's an interesting parallel
phenomenon
from the 1960s in the us which is the
the emergence of what were called junk
bonds
and the reason i bring it up is because
the insight that people had like michael
milken and others
was that companies that couldn't get
credit couldn't get access to the bond
market because they were too small
didn't have the the kind of reputation
were nevertheless excellent credit risks
and so milken and others created the
market for
interest bonds that these small
companies could
borrow with and they knew they were
on average good for them this was a
early data-driven type of application
but the data of course was slow in
coming and not in real time
and you know what's different today
is that you can make that same kind of
determination
with ai and the deep learning and you
know
being able to look at somebody who you
say
as you say doesn't have the traditional
banking
parameters of he's a good
credit risk yeah you can tell
from other uh data that
is less obvious yeah that the ai has
told you
he's a good credit risk the old cliche
is
that um if you want to get a loan from a
bank you have to prove that you don't
need it
yeah it was the that was the old
attitude and now
um because of fintech and firms like
yours
people who need credit and can't prove
that they
wouldn't otherwise need it are able to
access it
and this is a revolutionary change yeah
so you know in fact uh one
way and a big understanding that we got
in the last three four years was
how do we expand the market and you know
what we realized was
that if you go for the perfect score for
the banks you know the market is
one percent of the total market and is
it profitable
because those people would want uh you
know credit at a very minimum rate of
interest
so what we realized was the market is
not eventually
about having the least default rates the
market is to understand
how big that you can create market and
even if the default rates are higher
and the consumers are taking that credit
even at that higher rate
and able to return that is trying to
create that that kind of a market
so you know and that that was not
possible if you do not
have uh you know large sets of data
you know a lot of people and think you
know uh
and and this is for a lot of people who
want to be in the fintech industry where
i would want to add across
see a lot of people think you know uh
the
ai and and and fintech will be able to
make decisions very quickly
across on that front but ai and
everything is
all about how much data that you can
produce right
and there's some sets of data that is
available with you with your credit
history reports
right there's some sets of data that
will be available with you on the phone
the kind of contacts you have the kind
of you know
the transactions that you're doing
monthly on your credit cards
and the kind of transaction that you're
doing on your debit cards and the kind
of
phone payables that you're doing or
electricity bills that you're doing and
if you can put all together
you can cluster a guy into a
segmentation and then
when you're able to cluster a guy then
you can actually identify him what is
the kind of a quality of a customer that
he is and what is the quality of that he
can play across
so so that's where the whole invent lies
you know
not just in the large set of data that
is
available and then you have to
understand and
even identify the social behavior and
stuff like that and
you know the other thing that we would
really want to talk about is
the biases that we create in the
artificial intelligence
or or the biases that we had created
earlier in the rule-based engines right
in the rule-based engine they realized
or somebody like for an example which
has no credit is not going to like do
well
right that was a bias across and there
was bias across
male female you know on color and
everything across
but when artificial intelligence able to
pull out our machine learning are able
to pull out sets of
individuals and match out to them and
understand that what the behaviors are
they're able to take all those biases
but even
even in in when you're building up a
model which is a credit model for
a large institution people who want to
work with they need to understand as
much as data they can
in panel in that data sets that's where
they will reach a perfect
situation where we'll be able to pick
predict
and figure out what's the best for the
customer and from the manufacturer or
the lender
yeah that's an excellent an excellent
insight in that
this is one of the areas of ai
in general of understanding biases and
and what you're saying is that um
on one level it fights the biases that
pre-existed before
uh ai um and then the other challenge of
course is to make sure that they don't
get
replicated or the new biases aren't
introduced
so
how has all of this
changed the needs of fintech firms for
talent
i mean where do you need
to bolster or what skills do you need to
to search for in order to be able to
scale up and
and continue to expand yeah
so see uh there are uh you know the the
fintech
uh has three or four more challenges
across on that front
you know the first is customer
onboarding right
then is about creating a perfect ui ux
right for that so that it is easy across
and function
and then there are the needs of a
physical structure building apps
uh talking to apis stuff like that so
there is
a different sets of individuals that
would be required to create these apis
able to talk to many apis simultaneously
and these are a functional java and or
or
or people who do uh a lot of php and
stuff like that and then
then becomes the back end the artificial
intelligence people who know
uh you know a lot of our people who know
a lot of python uh people who can
understand and can build
models people who are statisticians who
can physically
identify these sets of data right and
then can produce across on that front
so when somebody looks at uh at
a fintech he doesn't just look at it
just only bases on the artificial
intelligence
just do not look at it at everywhere
across on that front so fintechs open
that pandora where
a lot of these tech people would be
required
across those functions which will help
consumer make up better financial
decisions
so but what happens is that the best
talent uh you know or the best you know
remuneration comes from where is where
you're able
to give a much better result
where you know a lot of uh engineers who
have experience in artificial
intelligence
uh people who are you know have uh
you know are able to understand and
build these
models where this creditor becomes so
they are get paid really well across on
that front
so while uh you know there is a famous
thing that i've
i learned all my life is saying degrees
you pay for education is free
right right so what happens is and and a
lot of my friends who would be watching
across here in india is these are
perfect platforms like simply learn and
stuff like that because this was not
available when we were young in college
when i started this was not available
and this is
and you know i i i am so glad that
all this is available in such a
structured manner by you know by a lot
of these players put together
otherwise we used to you know hover 50
of our time to learn the right
you know papers and then to understand
from them and then to build our own
stories around it
now at this period of time there are so
many of these courses available which
you should be able to invest in because
everything that you know
is getting better by five days so you
know you need to keep learning again and
again
so it is best for you to go all about
understand
and understand what's new embrace
yourself with new because
you know typically artificial
intelligence will even
eat you know computer
jobs too if you are doing something
which is not prevalent across on that
front
because that's what you need to
understand you need to be updated
so my understanding to this is that uh
you know you need to keep
uh start wherever you want to start with
in whatever you like and then keep
learning yourself
with you know such online courses
understand them well
and you will be then be run after by the
hr's of these large fintechs where
they'll see
value into you because you know what
they are actually looking at
so to be prepared uh for for a person
who's trying to make a career in fintech
he needs to understand that
he needs to do as much as he can
and understand a lot of these courses
and physically understand where he wants
to be
the the perfect match in that criteria
yeah
and and you know being here in
california today i'm uh
reminded of the the image of surfing
which is
you know you have two choices when
you're surfing you can either
ride the wave and and
rise up with it or you can get
swamped by it and when you talk about
how artificial intelligence
affects careers in technology
if the wave is the artificial
intelligence
can do more and more of things that
humans once
did your challenge
as a technology professional is to surf
that wave
and stay in the sector of things
artificial intelligence isn't ready to
do yet
or in in the domain of
finding the interesting problems and
defining the problems that artificial
intelligence needs to solve so
there's always um yeah
sorry sorry i'm so i have a viewpoint in
this is
see when electricity came a lot of
things changed
you know in 20s all those manual things
that we require people to pull
push right was changed by electricity i
think
yeah yeah uh
exactly and then and you know steam
power before
that in in since that computing so
um all of these things where we said
um there have been a number of
projections that said uh from the 1950s
that um by 1980
all of the women in a particular society
will have to be
employed as bank clerks because the
amount of paperwork to be done
will be so vast and in in any time that
you look at a projection like that
you have to recognize that um
you know the world will be changing and
there will be ways to solve these
problems so that people have
other better things to do and that's
really
the kind of thing that we're looking at
um so
we're getting to the point i think where
we might want to ask
the um q a questions
um you did have a couple of poll
questions uh queued up i didn't know
whether you wanted to ask one or
more of those yeah yeah so i think i
covered them across
uh so if there is any question that that
that wants to be covered so i'm happy to
answer that
okay so we'll go into the question and
answers and
um for this we've had uh
folks who have been looking at the um
chat and the q a and putting together
some of the lists of questions so i'll
ask some of those and see if we can
cover
as many as possible in the next uh 15
minutes
um so
vibhoff asks uh rishi how
significant was your master's degree in
your current role would have you been
as successful without it oh yeah
good question yeah see uh that opened my
eye
i you know i had a very different view
uh and
uh without being able to understand
world uh from outside india
i wouldn't have understood what the pace
it was changing down to
and having the understanding basically
of
how the world will change down to so the
first point was
i was looking in india and in that
period of time i thought oh this is
going to take 10 years and 5 years and
stuff like that
so when i did my degree i understood
that this is this is going to be cheap
you know and
uh everything is going to hovering
around giving best services and when i
learned about that
and it opened my mind uh that's what
changed and
that was a very drastic change in my
career and life cycle yeah
okay um we have
sandeep who asked a question um they
finished a
certification program in data science
and they're looking for opportunities
where would you
direct them uh
so yeah so uh if he's done data science
i think there will be a lot more
opportunities
in lot of payment banks a lot of
opportunities
uh in a lot of credit risk model
companies in the fintechs which are
defining about credit all of them are
hunting about them
uh because uh data science is something
that everybody needs and
a lot of less talent available even at
this period of time
okay um
we have a question from sandra who asks
how can fintech help a young
entrepreneur who hasn't
yet completed their degree
uh can you repeat the question yeah
sandra
asks how can fintech help a young
entrepreneur who hasn't yet finished
their uh studies is that
something that um so
looking at me from the biases right yeah
so see uh fintechs uh will be maybe
able to make them understand and get
them some credit uh
to finish their education
and if they need credit for that because
they might look at them
and understand them they are bright
students and they'll be able to make it
out
and then give credit across from that
trend so i see that as a perspective
as that period of time yeah okay uh
shubham asks um
would you agree that indian fintech has
been following
mainly an uh
and well let me let me read this
question again
would you agree that indian fintech has
been mostly following an eastern west
market strategy
for its business models you know what
are some of the areas that are unique to
india versus
the rest of the world yeah
so see uh uh in india uh yes
uh there are models that were started in
the us and some of them were got copied
in india and they were implemented
i think that's a very different
structure but a lot of these
fintech models will not be successful if
you
go go local you know because if you
don't understand your own
uh understanding of consumers or you're
not able to understand that
india the price sensitive market india
has uh
people who can't read in one simple same
language
they are about more than you know
hundreds of language where consumers
uh understand that and if they are not
able to address that issues
uh you know they will not be able to
bring a large market to them
because a lot of people feel like the
english is a language but if you are
actually able to
understand uh you know the languages of
people and their people who have
a lot more uh money available to them
their h
is also but they're not able to
understand that so
i think an indian strategy is to
identify the large market
identify build a lot of consumers who
were not
into uh in the mainstream uh on the
structured data
so that was something that was required
differently
but currently we don't see somebody
being able to do
that successfully but yes a lot of them
are trying and hopefully within the next
three five years when the data would get
available
uh we would have clear winners which
have originated from here
um we touched a little bit on this
in the um in the
earlier uh discussion uh
arphito who is in the youtube live
audience asked a question
what about ethical and economic
risks of ai and fintech what what about
things like data security
need to be worked on and or bolstered
now
yeah so so there are two different that
i think
there is ethical data i mean you're able
to understand
uh not able to you know when you are
somebody is giving you a lot sets of
data
you need to help customers understand
that they are getting be open to them
what you have an access to them
so that's ethical part of it not
covering it with the ui ux layers and
saying i'm just creating
this new picture and i'm creating all
your contacts and everything across on
that front
so once the ethical part of it and then
there's putting a data security layer so
that
you know if there are people who are
trying to hack into your systems you are
able to protect them
from getting leaked across
related to that question uh another
question
from jadeep is
with more people coming in more more
consumers using fintech and
more fintech firms um
what type of fraud prevention
is is becoming more important or coming
to the forefront
and does it depend on deep learning
yeah so uh i i think i i answered it's
see fraud prevention is two elements is
one is customer onboarding and secondly
when
the uh you know when a transaction is
getting built
right the transaction is carried by the
original person is the first thing that
you need to
into ensure right so there were typical
models
of on a mobile otp which are being
you know which are being taken away by a
lot of fraudsters and understand them
so those things are going to get changed
very quickly
and the deep learning is going to
understand whether
uh you know the transaction that you're
making the time that you're spending on
a mobile phone to
click a screen how many multiple times
that screen is getting clicked
right and and understanding your early
behaviors and saying that you are not
withdrawing such large money
right so that deep learning models will
be able to identify
all these frauds coming across on that
forefront so there are two parts that i
mentioned
is what once you onboard identify this
is the same person who's on boarding
secondly when he's making transactions
he need to make secure about him and
nobody else
should be able to transact on his behalf
is where the winning
happen would from from a fintech point
of view and from the deep learning point
of view
yes uh and as you mentioned you can you
can see some of the parameters that
that identify him by behavior or other
factors
yeah sorry yeah so say the thousands and
other uh
methods because it's again about your
access to which device
are you logging into device uh your or
your time taken
to actually fill a password your time
taken there are the millions of factors
with fintech will be able to evolve
saying that from your login where you're
copy pasting you know
you you can actually figure this out uh
you know if but
it is that the fraudsters are sitting
day in and day out to figure this out
right they have more than actually
people who are actually preventing
so they overcome that's a good point
yes so because from them uh you know
this
billion dollar for an individual it's a
hundreds of rupees or a thousand
rupees so his incentive is much higher
right so he works
much more than that but that's where
fintech would be able to identify on
that front yeah
excellent yeah i'm sure that uh some ai
is
is saying that um anybody who's trying
to
identify as steward online isn't really
him if he doesn't have to enter his
password
attempts at least three or four times
before he remembers what his actual
password was
um venet asks
and this is uh i think fundamental to
your business model
um but you might want to just
recap because i think one of the
aspects of the people in the audience is
understanding the practical uh way
that technology works within
fintech so the question vinit has is
when banks offer personalized offers to
customers
are they looking at our behavior
our spending our balances what are the
you know what are the factors that
you're building into
the um the ai model that says
this is the advice we want to give you
these would be offers we can offer you
yeah so so traditionally banks used to
work on
the ability to pay uh and the intention
to pay so the ability was how much money
that you have
and uh and your credit history would say
that
your intentions to pay these were the
two parameters that
that started in 90s and 2000s across now
these parameters are changing across on
that front
uh where where they're building and
saying that they look
they might look at your they might look
at at your current income
and versus your current credit history
and your available income
so that you can take credit to so they
make personalized offers to you where
they identify
that you have money that you can pay for
the next
few years with the kind of industry that
you work in with the
with the kind of remuneration increase
that they're looking at to you and
they're quantifying and qualifying you
with those offers based on that uh and
with a lot of artificial intelligence uh
people will be able to identify that
okay there's a person who's who's
improving
you know has from last 10 years that
even got to a 25
raise every year he's a bright guy
they'll be able to identify
based on regression see regression uh uh
you know functions were very prevalent
till you know
machine learning takes over which is
able to predict
also much better regression can tell you
from the past data
right where the machine learning can
build that past data
accumulate your behaviors and
identifying the future scopes
is able to predict the future and able
to give you credit
uh without having much hassles for you
in building up documents and stuff like
that
yeah that's an amazing thing having just
completed a
refinance of my home mortgage
it's a amazing difference in terms of
all of the documentation that was
required all of the verification that
was required
and things that you would think that
data would be able to cover and and
that would be available to the the
institution
without my having to furnish it so i'm
looking forward to
you know the spread of fintech to make
our lives easier um
and so what are the fundamental uh
you touched on it before but what are
the fundamental technologies the
different
technologies again if you could recap
that that you use in the fintech
industry
what are the what are the particular
platforms and areas that people
so again i defined uh it's the
onboarding uh the onboarding
requires a lot of ui ux customer
experiences across
uh then it is about the backbone the
backbone is about how do you connect
a one person to the server server
connects back to you gives you result
which is api
right across from that front and how do
you do that on on on either php platform
java platforms or
these other sets of platforms and then
how do you making these decisions
happens the algorithms that we are
talking about
the algorithms are running on which back
end how they are operating
how they are communicating how they are
figuring out the results so these are
the three
clusters of what do you talk about
fintechs that are available at this
period of time
sorry and uh we have several people
asking about
the role of blockchain how is it
currently being used
in fintech how do you see it being used
in the future
yeah so it's it's just the start of the
blockchain right
my understanding to this is this is
gonna drastically change
everything the next three five years
right and
uh you know what we see currently the
ledgers and everything
would become the basics of everything in
the next three five years or maybe
quickly at times we are not able to
identify the change
right but uh at this point of time i
would say that only two to five percent
it is just acceptability
people are trying uh people are moving
forward yes
uh the enthusiasm uh towards
a blockchain and being able to adapt and
what the blockchain will be able to do
on on frauds and risks will be very
different
what it is currently and will become a
base which will
open the society to an open structure
help consumers a lot and helps banks a
lot
help infrastructure cost a lot because
you know at a period of time when you
think there are millions of profiles of
consumers
you know banking into different banks
and stuff like that imagine a world
where where everything is all together
you're
able to make up a decision very quickly
imagine a world
where you are actually clustered into
the right fit
because blockchain will be enabled to do
that very quickly rather than having
structured data lying somewhere here and
where you talk about api bankings and
and structure like that okay so it's a
transformative technology
correct yeah um
we have a question from more than one
person
who asks um how would somebody who's
looking to enter the fintech
industry what what skills and and areas
should they be uh looking to acquire
so uh uh i would say if you want to
really grow brick
uh you know try to understand
a lot more uh you know uh you know and
understand the basics of artificial
intelligence
and its various subsets across on that
front
if you're able to identify and you find
interest in them and do courses or
able to identify them that will be a
short
good remuneration package across on that
front uh then my
second thoughts would be that if you are
able to understand as we were mentioning
another earlier the future is blockchain
right uh so if you're building in
something for the next three five years
you need to understand that basics
across on that one
uh then the highly demand paid service
at this period of time is
how do you build a user in from a
consumer so you are you a tech
is is a billion dollar for somebody like
that so because
so you know it's an interesting thing
that the left swipe
uh for someone created a billion dollar
industry for them i mean
i think the best thing that you know
anybody could do
to a matchmaking industry was left in
the right swipe
yeah somebody did it right and i just
want to name the company but
what it did was that the company uh you
know it just ensured a lot more
consumers came in and they were able to
understand and identify and onboard very
quickly and they really liked it
right it was a ui ux that made that
company right it was not
right everything else was later so
nothing is small
so user interfaces are as important uh
you if you're able to identify
patterns and habits and you know there
are people who are actually
understanding uh the how the thumb is
used over a mobile phone
right and they will able to identify
which is the hot spots and how you just
make
everything on the app over the thumb
rule and make it easier
right so that's what it is all about
yeah so yeah so
anything you want people to use should
be within the range of their thumbs
exactly
yeah go ahead yeah so that's
that's the part of it so i'm just saying
all those segments exist in fintech
so whether it's all the the backbone of
the technology the data servers
uh you know the oracle so you know mysql
servers everything is required
uh
that connect to them is getting
important and gets you
much uh much better remuneration because
when somebody is hiring in fintech he
understands oh you understand this layer
also
then it becomes easier to hire him and
give him a much
valuable uh you know you know product or
resource
or or stuff like that yeah okay there
was a little bit of a break in your
voice when you
mentioned that last point so what was
the thing that you said that was very
important in that
so i was saying is that understanding
all the three layers are you know
understanding and putting all layers
together so if you know
you if you know a database server and if
you're able to communicate
uh uh with with the apis of different
service providers and if you can do it
with
with a with a segmentation and do
analysis on the database
in terms of any any small programs on uh
on python and stuff like that makes uh
your
you know your you make makes you much
more important and one
one man army in a company and and gives
you a lot more recognition and
administration
so it's basically understanding the the
full stack of the
fintech world
to use a uh a buzzword
um i think the last question we have
time for
is from akansh who asked for kind of a
very broad question but what do you
think the world will look like in 2050
so i will say you know
we will be all wired that's my
understanding
so all your data or your moments
should give you help and be able to give
you much more health
because that you would be wired in terms
of inside your body
right based that's what i see
you know we are already cyborgs right we
use our mobile phone
right you'll become a part of your body
that's what i see
and based on you'll be able to you will
be monitored
if you want an access you will be given
a free service
if you don't want an access you will be
charged for it that's what i see
so as a as a as a background
i see that it will be never
there'll be only an apps you know which
will do
and maybe apps would be redundant at
that period of time
they'll be able to understand what
you're looking at and be able to give
your solution much before then
i i absolutely agree with you and i
think that we will get to that point
in steps and one of the steps um
and we've seen it attempted but one of
the steps will be
adding a layer outside of our bodies in
our clothing
in our eyeglasses
and other aspects so that
what we how we move where we go what we
see
what we hear and what we say can all be
with permission of course be um
fed into the the ai that will be
helping us and then once we're
comfortable with that
as you as you said i do believe uh
people will look for ways to make that
more permanent by
moving it inside the skin rather than
just being the outside
shell so it's it's an interesting world
and and um one of my hobbies is writing
science fiction screenplays
so you've probably just given me an idea
for a new movie but
um this has been a wonderful discussion
we're at our
our time and um so what i want to do
is um before i say goodbye i
do want to share a couple of things with
the audience
about upcoming information
and let me do that here
here we go
so we do want to ask one last poll
and i think it relates to something that
you mentioned about
what you need to do in order to stay
ahead of um
the tide of
technology so let me
this
so two parts to the question what
skills are you interested in learning
you and the audience um
what skills do you think will make you
more valuable either in the field you're
in or if you want to pivot into fintech
or whatever you're preparing for in our
digital economy
and then when do you think you'd want to
start
acquiring those skills
or as people say when would today be
i'm sorry when would today be the best
time to start
and
all right we'll close the poll
and share the results
um by far most people are interested
in data science and a.i
and a good number of you have said
that yes today is the best time to start
so with that said um
i would like to thank rishi uh i've
given you here his uh
linkedin contact information i'll leave
that up on the
screen for a bit but
he's been very generous with his time
and and his knowledge today
and so um again thank you
for thank you so much thank you
appreciate it thank you and
we're going to uh conclude the webinar
with a reminder that
we have um
a skill up program that simply learned
has introduced
the skill up program is access to our
self-study
materials uh separate from our
live virtual classes and other blended
courses oops sorry
oh sorry um
and i'm going to put into the chat again
the
link to
that
so over 300 in demand skills
video self-study content in a number of
different
technologies and you can
go to the link that's in the chat and
get to
our skill up pages
and if
you find value in that we then hope that
you will
proceed on with your simply learn
training
into our other courses our next webinar
is with um
ritu chakraborty she
is the co-founder and evp of team lease
services
um and that's part of the group with
freshers world
expert on jobs and
job placement and she is going to share
with us next tuesday
it's a morning webinar different from
most of our our webinars
morning in in indian time and this is
um expert tips on making 2021 the best
year for your career
which is maybe counterintuitive because
it doesn't seem like a very good year
so far but uh she has advice for you
on how to turn
change to your advantage and
that's also in the chat you can take a
look there click on that and register
for that webinar
again it's tuesday may 4th
9 a.m india time in north america that's
an evening webinar
starting at 8 30 uh
p.m pacific time and i apologize for the
mistake on the side
slide 8 30 p.m pacific time
11 30 p.m
uh eastern time we don't expect a lot of
people to be staying up on the east
coast of the u.s
but having said all that
we and we thank you all
for being here at the webinar today
um and we hope that you will keep in
touch with us on
our social channels facebook twitter
linkedin you can pretty much find us by
just typing simply learn
and we hope to see you at the future
simply learn events and we hope that we
can
help your journey to
gaining more skills for the digital
economy that concludes our webinar
and we thank you very much
you